when uh Clarence was dying do I have it
right that you went to see him and that
he actually passed away you were sitting
and strumming the guitar to him yes
that is just so you went to see him you
had your guitar and you felt I assume he
was not conscious at that point but you
felt like you felt internally like hey
maybe Clarence can hear me
I had a feeling you could hear me
because he squeezed your hand
uh it was when I first went to see him
he had there was some response to your
voice and to you being in the room it
felt like so I just was
took a hunch and said well you know I
knew I knew that I knew that he was
going to die and so
I just
brought the guitar in and just played
you know I strummed a song called uh
Land of Open Dreams yeah Land of Open
Dreams and
um why did you choose that
uh it's about passing over to the other
side you know it's about
life and death and so you're sitting
there with Clarence yeah and you're
losing a dear friend a guy who like
really believed in you and you believed
in him yeah and you started to strum
yeah and you were alone in the room with
him or are the people around that was uh
I'm trying to think uh he had some of
his his relatives his brother was there
um
I think Jake is never you know his
nephew was there
um and there were a few other people you
know but it was just a very tiny little
space and and uh
uh so it was just
grab your ticket and your suitcase
Thunder is rolling down this track
[Music]
you don't know where you're going now
but you know you won't be back
well darling if you're weary
Lay Your Head Upon my chest
we'll take what we can carry
and we'll leave the rest
big wheels roll
through Fields where sunlight streams
[Music]
meet me in the land of
Hope and Dreams
yeah well I will provide for you
and I'll Stand By Your Side
[Music]
cause you'll need a good companion now
for this part of the ride
here leave behind your sorrows
[Music]
stay these last
well tomorrow there'll be sunshine
and all this Darkness pass
well big wheels roll
through Fields where sunlight streams
oh meet me
in a Land of Hope
and dreams
this is the whole thing that goes
this train carries Saints and Sinners
this train I don't remember now Carriage
loses and weather you know it's it's a
beautiful song it's it yeah it's it's a
hymn you know it's a hymn and uh did you
have any idea you'd sing that to him or
did it just sort of happen spontaneously
yeah I I don't know how it was just sort
of uh
it was a song we were playing at the end
of the night and it was one of the last
songs that uh
Clarence and I worked on a stacked solo
together on and uh
[Music]
you know so it was
uh
it was it's it's it's it's it's it's
probably one of my best songs of the
past
20 or 30 years you know